time for a staff change the new crew has
arrived
the others can go home lokillo is
looking for his survival suit without it
he can't leave the soup would protect
against cold if the helicopter went down
second officer p author appeared to
kofsky is going home to poland leaving
the project and next time we go we're
gonna join us somewhere in dogger bank
or somewhere on to UK sector more
helicopters in the new job gotcha
captain Kaitos wife and three children
are waiting for him at home in England
at last a suit is found for leak hello
fear a bit small pho tonight they'll
take the glory of the advertiser killer
won't be there when the wind farm is
finished his two-week tour of duty is
over out here in the North Sea
everything works like clockwork
the helicopter ride alone costs a
thousand euros per person then there's
the taxi and flight home these offshore
specialists are in demand so they can
expect this kind of treatment
back here only one last wind turbine
remains unfinished its rotor blades
still have to be fitted but work has
ground to a standstill because it's too
windy the halton construction is an
expensive one costing several thousands
of euros a day the assembly operator is
still here just have to wait the weather
forecast says the strong winds will keep
up for the next four days the stewardess
is at least have something to do they're
getting the cabins ready for the new
arrivals in the offshore branch you're
either working flat out or sitting
around twiddling your thumbs grenade
pixel has got accustomed to the unusual
working conditions but it's not
everyone's cup of tea people come and go
many don't like working offshore because
of the choppy seas or because they're
away from home so long this is nice on
top it's not the kind of job where you
get up and start work at 8am and then
clock out at 4pm and drive home again
it's not like that you have to be
flexible it's on it all sides on click
severs I
then to everyone's surprise the winds
drop a day later they get to work in the
middle of the night the team probably
only has three hours to hoist the rotor
blades 100 metres up onto the turbine
we'd loosen the screws and look to see
if everything was clean and that there
were no screws or nuts left behind poor
weather was forecast but we've been
lucky enough to get a window of
opportunity of several hours and now
we're lifting the rotor blades one jar
it's see much done
it's amazing to watch the precision with
which they move the 100-ton load
you
and they managed to mount the blades in
just two hours and complete the last
wind turbine it's good news a last one
finished yeah well I'm really well
really smooth it's good to see it
finished more than happy glad it went up
that it went alright perfect weather
this wind park will produce enough
electricity for four hundred fifty
thousand households clean energy
produced with zero carbon emissions the
men are proud of their work the wind
park is finished it's time to head home
it's great because I can relax at home
for a bit the next project starts soon
we've got a lot of orders at the moment
there are not so many in Germany but a
lot of broad and this will increase
there's a big project going on at the
moment in France so from that point of
view I'm not worried at all 60
international specialists living on one
ship together they've assembled 80 wind
turbines far out in the North Sea
for weeks they've been working in what
must be one of the most unusual
workplaces in the world
you